about three weeks ago i said you'll know
that there's some
tension or a little bit of elbow room
when you start seeing background quotes
from
somebody close to the white house or
within the white house
who says something about uh kamala
harris that would make it
clear that she is the vice president
and so when i saw that i'm like that to
me that was kind of like it was kind of
the first time
you had seen a little bit of a brush
back pitch
and i don't know what's going on
internally because you never see anybody
they don't talk they don't do anything
um but that was definitely a little bit
of a just remember
i and also if i were if i were calmly
harassed i'd be mad
so before we get into the book let's
talk a little bit about just kind of
what's
going on in the world it's been a it's
been a weird year to say the least
um well actually let's talk about
sort of for your former job for a second
because press secretary
and jen posaki um i i've been giving her
a bit of a hard time on the show she
doesn't
seem particularly well equipped to do
this job she's always circling back
a lot of a lot of non-answers i i
suspect you've got
none
and she's perfected that art i suppose
but i'm guessing you have some sympathy
i have a different view
look um look they've only been in office
for six weeks
um there is a lot you don't know and
that's one of the reasons you would want
to circle back
um she does come to the job with a lot
more experience than i had because she
was
the spokesperson at the state department
under president obama
and that gave her two things one a deep
dive into foreign policy
which a lot of people don't necessarily
have unless you've come up through
you know that industry or that um
department
um it you have it takes a while to learn
all of those issues um
and she used to get a really hard time
from
a few reporters in particular james
rosen was one of them
uh from fox news but matt lee of the
associated press
he is an equal opportunity uh
tough reporter on everybody and they
used to have a lot of tangles and
remember she also got caught up in that
whole thing of spying on james rosen and
reporters
so she she comes to the job with a
little bit more
experience than many press secretaries
um
up to date um the other thing is if she
has a press corps
that is one there's not many people in
the room
because they are very strict on covent
protocol so there's probably i think
i think there's like 10 reporters total
in the room that
that makes it for a very different room
masks
also i think are a real barrier to
communication and
um even though somebody might try to
like hold their mask away
there's this whole thing going on with
you can't read lips you can't read
expressions there's all of that
and the other thing is i think president
biden is quite happy
not to drive the news and it's a weird
thing
because i think well you have the
opportunity why wouldn't you drive the
news every single day
they seem to have this belief and we'll
see how it turns out for them that
they can do their jobs in a very steady
easy way and i use that kind of phrasing
because
that feels like the pace of the
administration
is that partly just because the media
kind of likes them perhaps a bit more
than they like that trump fella so
you know they're not going to ride them
as hard it makes their job a little bit
easier
i have a different way of answering this
and i haven't
thought of this until just now because
i've really been asked but if you think
back to the press secretaries
everyone kind of represents their boss
very well
right so think of ari fleischer
tony snow and me scott mcclellan
uh we had the confidence of george w
bush you think of the press secretaries
even though
sean spicer was not press secretary for
very long he continues to be a part of
president trump's um
sort of orbit i would say uh the other
press secretary stephanie grisham a
little bit different she never
or she never briefed that might be a
little bit of a different one but i
think that jen
saki is just kind of in the approach
tone attitude of joe biden
and so maybe what you want from a press
secretary
uh one you might want some more answers
always
but you also want to know that what you
are getting from that press secretary is
what the president is thinking and how
he thought about it how they got to that
decision
i think that she's actually doing that
yeah do you sense that biden is actually
in charge of this operation because it
doesn't
really seem like he is i mean i hear
what you're saying
but i remember so many times do you
remember
how they said that carl was karl rove
was bush's brain
or that really did cheney was really the
one in charge of everything
it wasn't true and i i think about this
now you know the other day when they
uh did the attack on the um iranian
forces in syria
did you see the news that um they didn't
tell kamala harris until after
so to me i think yeah i think that he
is in charge yeah when when you see
something like that get leaked
not that they did the attack but that
the vice president didn't no
yeah what do you make of like that
process because it seems to me that
there's got to be something going on
there that allows that to get like
that's the story in an odd way
more than you know bombing a random
caravan i think you're with me love
talking to you because
nobody else has brought that up yes okay
this biden team has been the most
tight-lipped disciplined
no leaks no backbiting i mean people are
kind of bored
like wait we used to get what happens
even in any administration you would get
a little bit of that
but on the campaign trail they were very
disciplined
and i think that's partly because they
keep their circles so
small but really pretty interesting that
even as it grew from the primary
campaign into the general election still
no leaks hardly any background you
didn't get any color like
what's going on over there about three
weeks ago i said
you'll know that there's some tension or
a little bit of elbow
room when you start seeing background
quotes
from somebody close to the white house
or within the white house
who says something about uh kamala
harris
that would make it clear that she is the
vice president
and so when i saw that i'm like that to
me that was kind of like it was kind of
the first time
you had seen a little bit of a brush
back pitch
and i don't know what's going on
internally because you never see anybody
they don't talk they don't do anything
um but that was definitely a little bit
of a just remember
i and also if i were if i were kamala
harris i'd be mad
and then what have happened is you have
west wing versus vice president's office
there's always a little
tension there even though they they
handle it pretty well
so far and joe biden is actually quite
um
i'm gonna say solicitous but he tries to
be very inclusive
of kamala harris so even though
he is the president he will say i did
this and he'll stop himself saying
we did this and i think that's a little
bit out of respect
um and also maybe just his management
style that he wants it to look like
there's a team and a shared effort and i
think time will tell it's a little early
to say
so so while you're giving these guys
credit on sort of the
the competency of how they're managing
the thing how do you think we're doing
on the unity and healing front which we
that was that was the meme we got
starting on january 1st well really i
guess on the 20th
but really it's starting at the top of
the year it was like okay 2020 is gone
now we can begin the the year of unity
and healing that was the messaging for a
while we're not really hearing about it
anymore but
i i never felt that it really had any
had any value because we know if the
shoe had been on the other foot
this certainly wouldn't have been about
unity and healing
and uh the bipartisan effort to try to
do a coveted relief plan that they are
now calling the american rescue package
um that was like the whole idea was that
we're going to do this together
and pretty quickly it was clear that ron
clayne who is the chief of staff
is not for that at all again there's a
little bit of color
from the meeting that remember when
several of those republicans susan
collins romney portman
about seven of them they go to the oval
office to have a meeting with joe biden
to say
hey look you save 1.9 trillion we say
600 billion let's talk like maybe we can
figure out some things
and susan collins the senator from maine
reports that during that entire meeting
ron klain sat you know to the
president's side
out of out of eyesight from biden
and shaking his head the whole time nope
nope and she said she
knew in that meeting they have no
intention of making this
a bipartisan effort of course they would
love for some republicans to say oh yeah
sure okay
we'll do that um
it's interesting unity when you in any
general election you can find that a
majority of people
vast majority people will say they want
congress to work together to get along
to do
the right thing together and move the
country forward and
then that lasts for about three days in
this case it didn't even
get there at the time so it looks like
we're going to get 1.9 trillion dollars
of spending uh by a very slim majority
of democrats
and i don't think that you'll get i
don't think you'll get any republicans
to vote for it in the end
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell